welcome back nascar takes over las vegas
this weekend and the las vegas motor
speedway who is sponsoring this next
segment has a host of activities taking
place i went out to the track to get
more details
it is a big week in las vegas it is race
week when this is the biggest week of
the year for you is it not jeff well one
of two we have two nascar races we got
another one in october but it's
certainly one of the two so what is
going on what's the preparation right
now like for you well it's the early
part of the week so right now we're
getting the track ready and everything
from painting to making sure the seats
are cleaned off you know that we're
ready for everybody to come in the rvs
start arriving on wednesday hauler
parade is on thursday you get race cars
on the track on friday what is something
people watching the race that they're
maybe not a die-hard nascar fan what is
something they should be looking for
come race day i tell you it's something
i compare to hockey you have to go and
experience it to to really believe it
when you go to a hockey game and see how
fast they skate and how fast the puck
moves you cannot see that on television
it's the same way coming to a car race
you watch it on television and they're
all running the same speed but when that
same speed is 180 miles per hour and
they go past you you get a true
appreciation of speed how many fans are
gonna have here this weekend well
hopefully we'll have a crowd somewhere
upwards of 75 000 here on sunday for the
pennzoil 400 and we'll also have races
on friday and saturday as well truck
series friday night vanity series on
saturday afternoon and in this area
we're in is this pit road you're on pit
road so this is where they're going to
be changing their tires getting fuel
making adjustments repairs to the car
hopefully those pitstops are no more
than 11 or 12 seconds and then they call
booty down the pit road and get back in
the race they come down here we're doing
four tire changes gas enough and they're
doing that in 11 seconds well if you
don't have to put fuel in we can do it
in about six seconds we can change four
tires in about six seconds they have to
wait on the fuel so it's going to take
about 11 to 12 to make a full pit stop
if your car is empty yeah this is
incredible we're between turn one and
turn two how steep the bank is this well
we've got 20 degrees of banking right
here it actually starts at 20 degrees
progresses all the way up to 22 degrees
at the top you're probably about the
equivalent of a three-story building by
the time you get up there this is so
high yeah that's 22 degrees of banking
you're probably at least two and a half
three stories up if you try to build a
building here wow now when the cars come
around turn one into turn two how fast
are they going probably going to carry
somewhere a little over 200 miles per
hour into turn one that's going to be
the top speed now an average speed for a
lap here track records like 190 293 but
that's an average speed because they'll
get a little slower as they get through
the turn but when they're coming through
turn one getting into this
close to 200 maybe a little more now how
many cars start the race on sunday we'll
have 40 cars starting on sunday if
that's a full field now if there's 36
teams that are guaranteed in the race
but we could have up to 40. we can get
two cars wide three parks wide they can
go four wide if they're really brave
they're really brave they go four wide
but you'll see a lot of three wide here
on the restart it's going to be an
incredible weekend out here at the
racetrack before we go do you know who's
going to be doing the national anthem or
any opening ceremony uh yeah midland is
going to be our pre-race concert on
sunday really excited to have them there
for a number of grammys in fact they're
going to be up for acm awards on monday
night over allegiant stadium tierra
kennedy up and coming big machine artist
is going to be doing the national anthem
so be a nice little country music feel
to our pre-race it's going to be a great
weekend and you've got a very busy week
ahead of you jess we'll let you go thank
you my friend
head over to eight newsnow dot com slash
contest for your chance to win a family
four pack to the pennzoil 400 at the las
vegas motor speedway and be with us
tomorrow when i'm back at the track and
behind the wheel of the nascar i will
tell you this we're out there last week
i hit 165.
165. that's awesome i was going to say
did you get to take a lap i can't wait
to see that it's crazy turn and burn dad
turn and burn next time take me with you
i'll probably pass out we should rate
let's go race seriously okay i'll do the
flag you do the flags on your market the
old school days were like you throw them
like that yeah
that'll be me
what are we looking at for the weather
well first of all we don't need all our
little logos like i need chef nanny
bubby on this side and like
you know zero raise
yeah it's only a matter of time